so anyway we have a thanks mr. Richter
you're welcome take a great show tonight
we're gonna have there we go
I'm gonna have Andy Andy you're coming
yeah
what's going on I'm sorry Conan it's I
just got a lot of fans down here at
comic-con
they're always
they're always they're always asking me
to sign my comic books
wait a minute sign your comic books whoa
you have comic books yeah I've published
my own comic book for quite a while now
it's very popular I mean look what are
you talking about I didn't know you even
had a comic book well sure I did here
take a look at this for the past I don't
know
twenty four years and ten months or so
I've been inspired to write and produce
my own comic book series Rhett dingus
wanted to be your traditional likable or
manly or even good superhero that would
be too predictable read dingus well he's
the friggin worst that has nerd sales
though people love to hate this guy this
is the issue where the red bengis is
desperate need for attention and
approval is so great it creates a
literal black hole take it out I never
got what I needed when I was young
this is the moment in issue 113 where
red bengis does his patented hip handle
dance for the people of Planet X or who
see it as an act of war thousands die
well this is the first time we see the
red bengis is stupid space-cruiser
didn't see such hot crap when he's
behind that thing this is like an early
sketch we'll be learning at the red
dinguses foraging story see he was
bitten by a poisonous tick and that that
sapped him of all is pigment and
testosterone and gave you stupid
deformed haircuts he's so gross
oh yeah this is hot this is the red
dinguses incredibly competent sidekick
handsome Andrew fixes all these red
things and snes's and doesn't get credit
for it
check out that package
I just really wanted to create a true
intergalactic jackass a universal
annoyance that alienates all species I
can asked all the time Andy where'd you
come up with this idea what's the
inspiration for red dingus and I guess
my answer is
[Music]
oh you all want me to sign a copy for
you I'm good I'm really here I'll give
it to you after the show
great yeah terrific all right yo and and
that's okay yeah okay
hi
and you say sales are good all there
you